1983 sera l'année zéro de l'informatique
celle où nous serons capables de
commencer notre effort ou seul où nous
aurons décidé d'abandonner ce n'est pas
moi qui le dit mais jean-jacques
servan-schreiber le président du centre
mondial de l'informatique qui place
beaucoup d'espoirs dans cette
technologie pour la communication la
formation est aussi la solidarité entre
les hommes
nous le retrouverons directe de ce
centre mondial en compagnie de georges
leclercq
nous rentrons maintenant dans le centre
mondial de micro informatique situe en
plein coeur de paris avenue matignon
ce centre qui à mercredi à midi vous le
devinez est remplie d'enfants
en fait c'est un centre ouvert à tout le
monde de 10 heures à 20 heures le matin
bien sûr il est plutôt réservée aux
groupes scolaires ou aux groupes
constitués qui ont pris rendez-vous
l'après-midi
n'importe qui peut venir s'initier à la
micro informatique alors n'importe qui
aujourd'hui nous avons des classes
maternelles nous avons beaucoup
d'enfants
cela vous montre un peu que la micro
informatique n'est pas du tout une
science compliqué en fait j'ai dit
science je devrais peut-être pas le dire
c'est plutôt une technique ou même un
art parfois et les bambins que vous avez
autour de vous sont là pour en témoigner
le but de ce centre a été lors de sa
création en novembre 80 par françois
mitterrand de promouvoir l'informatique
à la fois de façon culturelle et trouver
des machines pas très cher et de trouver
des ressources humaines dans le
tiers-monde avec cela mais depuis le
mois d'avril mai dernier physiquement
elle est ouvert ici vous avez donc ce
spectacle quasiment tous les jours
plus d'enfants de mercredi bien sûr que
les autres jours de la semaine alors
avant de passer la parole à jean jacques
servan shreiber qu'il présente ce centre
qui est ici je voudrais vous montrer un
peu comment l'informatique conc'air
différentes couches de notre pays et en
particulier l'industrie très précisément
je voulais vous montrer grâce à un
reportage de philippe dumez comment vos
pulver sont peut-être déjà fabriqué
grâce à l'informatique ça reportage à la
roche sur yon
l'industrie de l'habillement en france
n'a pas la réputation d'être innovatrice
dans ses méthodes de fabrication et
c'est ce qui lui vaut souvent des
problèmes de concurrence étrangère qui
entraîne pas mal de faillite chez nous
selon un sondage de notre confrère
industrie et technique
cette profession utilisent
l'informatique comme les deux tiers des
pmi surtout dans le domaine de la
gestion de la comptabilité est de plus
en plus dans le suivi de la clientèle
ce sondage fait également apparaître que
ce sont les entreprises qui ont commencé
à informatiser leurs productions qui
seront les plus dynamiques dans les
prochaines années à continuer dans cette
voie la société albert en vendée en fait
sûrement partie spécialisée dans le
vêtement pour enfants et pour jeunes
elle a commencé il y a deux ans par
remplacer un certain nombre de travaux
manuels par des ordinateurs
ici par exemple à partir d'un modèle
c'est la machine qui va faire les
calculs pour sortir des patrons dans
toutes les tailles désiré fait assez
surprenant
les employés souvent très peu qualifiés
n'ont pas trouvé la reconversion à
l'informatique trop compliqué et il en
apprécie même les avantages dans leur
travail
en cas de doute dans une opération cette
machine a découpé au laser fournira un
patron pour vérification un des grands
problèmes de la confection consiste dans
le stockage des modèles et des formes
et bien grâce à l'informatique il me
vient maintenant possible de stocker
indéfiniment sur des petits casse est
comme celle ci aussi nombreux que ceux
là et ici il y en a des centaines
et il tient dans ces deux cassettes tout
simplement
c'est tout simplement aussi à partir de
ses cassettes qu'un autre ordinateur va
poursuivre le travail quand on fabrique
deux millions et demi de vêtements par
an le moindre bout de tissu prend de
l'importance et là encore l'informatique
va permettre de placer au mieux chacune
des pièces pour le découpage futur afin
d'éviter les pertes
cette opération est donc plus facile à
réaliser et ce fait dix fois plus vite
qu'avant dans un local également dix
fois plus petit mais n'utilise plus que
trois personnes au lieu de six alors
l'informatique c'est peut être un peu
aussi le symbole du chômage
et bien non car
les économies que nous font réaliser ces
nouveaux systèmes nous permettent
d'obtenir des prix de revient
améliorer
qui nous permettent de vendre davantage
et ainsi de créer des emplois dans
d'autres secteurs à la piqûre ou en
administration par exemple si le coût de
l'heure de travail ils n'avaient pas
augmenté de 26% en un an
il est sûr que cette usine serait très
compétitive pour le reste et il faudra
encore innover et ce n'est peut être pas
un mal
alors monsieur servan-schreiber
concrètement est ce qu'avec la micro
informatique vous avez si dans ce centre
va pouvoir sortir de la crise a votre
avis il n'y aucun doute ya aucun doute
la crise c'est quoi des pays comme
l'europe des pays comme la france
quand l'amérique d'ailleurs ont pris du
retard combien veut dire cet industriel
dans la manière de fabriquer les objets
des rumeurs sur guy sur le japon nous
sommes en retard sur non seulement le
japon la corée forme au singapour l'asie
parce que l'asie s'est saisi de
l'informatique et que les robots
remplaçant les hommes travaillent jour
et nuit sans salaire travail très
précisément et dans tous les métiers y
compris les textiles que vous venez de
le voir donc la course a commencé entre
les robots qui sont imbattables pour
remplacer la main d'oeuvre et qui vont
arriver partout qui vont arriver en
france en particulier en europe et la
course entre les robots et les hommes
alors la chose et st
les robots tuent les hommes non formés
ils prennent leur emploi mais les robots
ont besoin d'hommes forts mais d'hommes
et de femmes formées depuis le plus
jeune âge jusqu'à beaucoup plus âgés
alors comment peut-on forme et donc des
jeunes à cette civilisation y aura le
robot gras seulement pas seulement les
jeunes mais tout le monde tout le monde
on peut former tout le monde au
savoir-faire sans lequel ces appareils
ne sont rien ça pareil c'est du fer
blanc on les fera facilement on les fera
très bon marché
tout le monde doit en avoir le problème
c'est de former les gens il faut que la
france devienne ce vaste chantier de
formation est par exemple l'un des
exemples quant à eux deux cette semaine
c'est que les l'ensemble des grandes
écoles de france de paris de toutes les
régions où ça c'est un plan très précis
des grandes écoles comment vous le voyez
c'est le président de la conférence des
grandes écoles qu'il a lancée avec
l'accord de ses cols labro collègues
tous les élèves sortant des grandes
écoles c'est à dire 12000 parents jeunes
gens et jeunes filles de 20 à 23 ans
vont se mettre à la formation des jeunes
chômeurs et je prends un exemple concret
c'est pas de la du futurisme un exemple
contraire
aujourd'hui mr une narain dans le
paiement christine nora qui est
professeur d'informatique à l'école et
télécommunications a formé et continuent
d'emmener des chômeurs et sa conclusion
que j'ai là sous les yeux que je vous
dis c'est qu'aucun de ceux aucun de ces
chômeurs qu'elle a formés au maniement
de l'informatique ou savoir-faire a été
est resté sans emploi ils ont tous
trouvé des emplois comme ça c'est parce
qu'on manque d'informaticiens
aujourd'hui alors qu'il marchait vous
avez pour développer l'informatique
alors le mot informaticien est un peu
trompeur on aura l'air dire ce grand
spécialiste des prix nobel non il ya
toute la gamme c'est que him vivier on
en manque de gens qui savent lire et
écrire
il faut apprendre l'informatique comme
on apprend à écrire c'est aussi sain ou
même plus simple ces enfants là en ce
moment avec leurs crayons électroniques
et leurs graphiques apprennent plus vite
à saisir et à maîtriser à utiliser
l'ordinateur que l'on apprend à lire et
à écrire les enfants et ensuite ses
enfants entraîne les adultes qui sont
les meilleurs enseignants alors c'est
une immense aventure qui doit nous
porter à l'optimisme à condition qu'on
rattrape ce retard est mort qu'est ce
que deviennent les héros c'est
maintenant mais qu'est ce que vous allez
faire pour rattraper le retard vous avez
une vocation mondiale s'appelle pas
centre mondial pour hier toute la france
d'abord de plafond alors ce n'est pas ce
centre à lui tout seul qui va pouvoir
informatiser le monde la france est
ridicule
vous avez en france déjà d'autres sans
le sort doit essaimé doit engendrer
toute une série d'autres centres en
france dans toutes les régions princesse
a commencé nous sommes à marseille nous
sommes à nevers nous sommes à
montpellier nous sommes à nancy je veux
dire des gens ils sont pas moi les gens
partout prenne des initiatives et dans
le monde et dans le monde
les pays du tiers-monde comme dakar au
sénégal comme la colombie où je vais ce
mois ci se met à faire passer
directement les enfants et les adultes
au savoir-faire en informatique plutôt
que de devenir manoeuvre industriel
condamné et d'autres pays comme le
canada s'associe avec la france dans
cette grande croisade mondiale pour la
formation des hommes le seul
investissement aujourd'hui qu'il faut
sur ces dans la formation des jeunes
ewen comment vous vous complétez avec
les 170 clubs de micro informatique en
france qui s'appelle microtel où les
clubs ademir dans les écoles les lycées
et grandes écoles dire 112 et grandes
écoles de constantine est il faut que
les centaines de clubs qui existent déjà
deviennent des milliers de clubs qu'il
faut que dans chaque village il y est un
club informatique à côté de l'école où
on apprenne informatique et allant
jusqu'au bout c'est à dire dans les deux
ans qui viennent il faut que chaque
français puisse chaque français dans les
deux ans qui viennent
vingt deux ans qu'ils puissent se servir
d'un ordinateur sans manuels sans cours
il se met devant
il parle avec l'ordinateur et il apprend
lui même les enfants ça déjà peur cela
ils vont l'apprendre à dieu et vous
allez voir ce phénomène qu'on a toujours
il ya deux ans nous avons parlé séjour
il ya moins d'un an quand on crée ce
sens ça paraissait utopique et lointain
aujourd'hui tout le monde sait ce que
c'est qu'un ordinateur
les gens ne croient pas encore qui
pourront s'en servir tous les enfants le
savent et savent s'en servir ceux qui
s'y met
il suffit de leur donner un donner un la
seule vrai obstacle à ce que les gens
maîtrisent le savoir faire pour que
l'ordinateur de vienne lors leurs
esclaves leurs moyens de créer leurs
moyens de travailler et qui trouve donc
des nouveaux emplois le seul pour nos
moments vrais obstacles et de
l'ordinateur devient trop cher il faut
des ordinateurs très bon marché - 2001
pour l'instant c'est 5000 francs la
plupart des machines que vous avez ici
aux minimes déjà un progrès moins cher
qu'en amérique par exemple il faut aller
beaucoup plus bas pour que chacun puisse
vraiment sans difficulté à voir un ordi
si l'ordinateur individuel la course est
entre le robot et l'ordinateur
individuel notre effort et les ponts
français la politique française doit
être vers l'ordinateur individuel à la
dilution de chacun pour les nouveaux
emplois un robot qui chasse les anciens
emplois n'est rien le robot sans les
hommes et des femmes qui vont lui
apprendre à faire des shows ils vont lui
apprendre en maniant l'ordinateur un
robot a besoin de centaines d'hommes et
de femmes qui maniait un ordinateur pour
lui faire faire des choses à ce robot et
c'est à ce moment là qu'ils fabriquent
pour presque en france aujourd'hui
la pétition du sourire parlons pas des
magnétoscopes nous ne fabriquons pas une
machine à écrire français nous les
importants nous trouver une compagne
photocopieuse française nous apportons
nous importons les machines outils
nous importons nous importons pourquoi
parce que les asiatiques fabrique les
choses l'une fabriquons des
micro-ordinateurs il ya ici des
micro-ordinateurs français rend bien sûr
mais c'est maintenant 83
une fois aller très vite il faut
fabriquer des centaines de milliers plus
des millions dans les deux ans qui
viennent
je suis sur la voie des airs vous
m'entendez oui très bien je vous demande
de rester avec nous parce que je
voudrais vous présenter maintenant une
illustration des propos que vous venez
de nous tenir et de tenir à ses enfants
au centre mondial de l'informatique a
trace